The UK is seeking trade deals...
...with new friends further afield in the Asia Pacific region.
The CPTPP covers a market of 500 million people...
...from Australia and Japan to Chile and Mexico,...
...countries around the Pacific Rim generating more than 13 percent of the world's income.
The immediate benefits to the UK might be limited.
CPTPP nations account for less than 10 percent of UK exports.
That's dwarfed by the massive 43 percent of UK exports going to the EU.
But longer term, the UK hopes to build stronger ties with nations...
...who provide UK manufacturers with components.
Tariffs would be cut on UK exports of food, drink and cars.
There would also be faster visas for business travel.
The UK will be the first country to join which wasn't there at the start.
And if all goes to plan, will be the group's second largest economy after Japan.
And the icing on the cake,...
...it may be a way of getting a warmer trade relationship with the US.
President Joe Biden has hinted at joining the partnership.